And you were also on a Korean television show...
...and became like the most popular watched television show in the history of the show.
That was my first international TV appearance, that Korean talent show called Star King...
...and it was like almost three years ago...
...like a long time ago, yeah.
So, I've been on the show two times.
The first time I was there, it was really amazing, the crowd was amazing. Koreans, I love them.
And I was just so shocked when I found out that they were inviting me again...
...because all the Koreans were like, talking about me. I was on the news all the time and...
...I just love them. I wanna go back there.
It must make you feel good inside when you go to a country that doesn't speak English...
...and yet they know your songs, they know who you are, they come and they support you.
It must be a great feeling.
I think the most memorable part when I was in Korea, when they called me by my last name.
They thought that my last name is my first name.
They were like, Pempengco, Pempengco. I was in the restroom.
When I went out, they were like, Pempengco! And I was like, huh?
They were like, Pempengco, Pempengco! They were like all waiting for me...
...but, they're calling my name, Pempengco. They thought that, that was my first name.
It's really, really funny and amazing.